thank you
[Music]
so I'm ready to [__] just register
Republican already oh yeah why are there
any benefits you're just confirming
everyone's thoughts that we're actually
just a bunch of closeted right-wingers
here at JK news it's time to step up
it's time to come out of the closet step
up to the place
come on or no what what's the Trump song
YMCA for some reason
Trump's huh but he dances the YMCA a lot
yeah MCA it's easy song to dance to so
remember how the Dems want to ban stoves
they're like we want to come after this
stuff yeah good Lord come on wait why do
they want us to not have stoves
[Music]
yeah there's whites there's white
supremacy in the Galaxy I like how now
things are getting
so divisive that it's like oh couches is
right-wing is your table it's cable TV
left room or right that's right wing
cable TV I think cable TV's right wing
what about jacuzzis jacuzzis is actually
because you know what's left wing sound
bath that's left wing that's true that's
the most left too much sound oxygen bars
oxygen bars left wing yeah yeah um
smoothie bars left left wing what about
drywall right right wing right I was
gonna say left Wings
eco-friendly Adobe is left left wing
okay yeah yeah solar panels so guess
what they're gonna crack down on next
this is what I'm done dude I'm ready to
[__] go register a propaganda and
wave a trump 2024 flag but I know it
[__] over small businesses somehow so I
run hot I run hot I'm a person who AC
air conditioning AC they're making air
conditioning right wing they're going
after air conditioning and they can't do
this I don't give a [__] I'm gonna move
to Texas that I'm gonna be a republican
I've run my AC all day the Environmental
Protection Agency of the EPA just gonna
say 40 production cut in 2024 for
hydrofluorocarbons the widely used Class
of refrigerants being targeted for their
claimed contribution to climate change
to refrigerants once as it is the modest
10 cut in force today has already cost
many hfcs or hydrofluoric carbons to
triple in price including hfc 410A which
is used in most home air conditioners as
a result replacing refrigerant from loss
from a leak has cost millions of
homeowners at least 150 to 250 dollars
more than it used to but next summer
stricter product production quotas will
be in effect likely sending refrigerant
costs through the roof and repair costs
with them they're targeting new systems
too a pending rule would outlaw all but
the most climate-friendly new Central
ACS by 2025 wonder how well they work
yeah you know what's funny like [__]
right oh my God you know what this
already is so when they change the Freon
the first time or I don't know if
they've done it a lot but people that
have the old air conditioning which I
believe runs free on 22 or something
let's say you get a like this building
right here right let's say it has the
old style air conditioning they put
something in the lease so that when that
thing breaks you have to replace it so
they're going to do the same thing with
this it's almost like [__] AC HVAC
companies are behind this lobbying right
because it's like if anytime something
gets updated and now you can't use the
old thing somebody's getting a big
[__] fat stack of money that's crazy
to Apples dude Apple phones and [__]
they give us the lightning cable oh
thanks now I can't charge charge
anything unless I buy all the new
donkeys and they know it's a model they
raised billions of dollars just but
Steve they tell you that it's for to
make sure that your phone charges faster
can I can I tell you guys for the
environment too is it a secret for us
because we're filming it's a secret so
me and my friend recently we were gonna
buy a HVAC company really yeah smart and
it was generating some good Revenue
great cash flow
and then the more we looked into it we
were like
dude HVAC companies there's so much just
like skills and knowledge involved like
because it's not it's not like
understanding the mechanics of a car and
then all of a sudden you could just fix
all the cars right because it's the it's
the same [__] like with it is
technically the same but they're all so
different in how it's done that it just
takes a lot of skilled professionals to
run the business and everything so like
and they have a ton of different
products so it's just got a huge skew
like meaning like a lot of like
different brands right different items
yeah Brands how to fix it whatever so
it's like damn it's a lot
but
it's a bear it's a super lucrative
business because it's like everyone's if
you're in a tropical desert whatever
it's a necessity and dude HVAC will just
cancel on you and don't give a [__]
they're like I'm taking the day if I can
give this [__] yep I made [__] 1200
yesterday I'm gonna make 1200 and they
never come on time nope you're just like
hey see you Thursday all right where are
you it's Thursday did I say Thursday I'm
coming Friday he goes hey where are you
it's Friday oh I meant next week Friday
they have all the power I got lucky I
had a HVAC guy in when I lived in Van
Nuys remember my own place he was like
this Russian guy and he was the [__] he
would just come out and you know how
like communities always lock the ladder
or whatever and you can't yeah the roof
ladder you can't ever reach the the
owner people he didn't give a [__] he
would just bring his own ladder stack it
against that ladder and climb up the
[__] and he's fixing my [__] in 25
minutes by the time that I moved I had
seen that guy so much because our old
place has so many problems with AC and
like leaks and stuff I'm not kidding I
told him I was moving to Vegas and he
cried and he hugged me oh wow you are my
number one business because every time I
was sabotaging come back and think
oh Steve I love feeling I've loved
feeling air conditioner unit with water
water every before every summer so it
would leak on your head
it had to be but yeah he cried and
hugged me because I showed him my new
spot and I was like yeah dude you should
come to Vegas and he's like he's like
thank you I don't have many friends oh
you know what this sounds like to me you
know whenever you you usually I was
political prisoner like when I'm a Putin
puppet
when you point out how like splinters
the government will tell you now you
can't take as many plane trips because
of pollution but the private jets are
all in perfect circulation still like
yeah it's not it's like it [__] over
the common man and then just or woman
and then it's just like oh but our
shit's still good sometimes I wanna like
sometimes I want to interview like a
die-hard Democrat and then just ask them
how they've been affected by the
policies you know like because they
because they're like this is what I want
right and I'm like okay cool like for
example in New York and California where
it's like a sanctuary state so the
Republican states are like okay if you
guys want to be Sanctuary States then
we're gonna just send all the illegal
immigrants to you guys because we're not
so now you have all these other like
refugees and you have crazy homelessness
and the streets are filled with people
like I want to just really just talk to
someone that actually votes and believes
in like super Democratic uh policies
like how do you feel because you voted
for this now the streets are filled with
like zombies and like you know
it's like you were saying earlier they
will tell a shopkeeper who just had his
business burned down that that didn't
happen yeah but I also think within the
Democrats you have like you have your
limousine you know liberals you have
your snobs who live in gated communities
that have white guilt and they're voting
for things
and then you have not even seen it
they're just voting based off of what
they're working class Democrats who've
been voting left for quite some time and
surprised the working-class Democrats
aren't automatically Republicans now
because of history no some of them did
but I think there's a long list of
historical reasons why because that's
why they called the big tent camp
because it's not one group it's like 50
different groups in one so they all kind
of pack together to get their points so
they might have to work with their enemy
like you know who we're about to recall
Newsome I was like yes this guy's
[__] crazy He's a hypocrite he has
[__] he's he's signed into a law like
Outlaw all [__] gas cards by 2030 or
whatever [__] but his uh his kid goes
to my friend's mom's school and hit
their secret service has two Tahoes
running outside of the school 24 7. they
don't not in Tesla they have guns too on
my security detail but you can't have
this person's trying to mandate vaccines
for kids when kids are really affected
at it by at all and I'm like okay cool
everyone's going to recall we're finally
on the same page yes and then
it got over not even close yeah I'm like
what the [__] is going on even during
all the Kobe controversy he gets to not
wear a mask he gets to go eat at
restaurants so I'm like who are these
Democrats that are so down for them and
what do they see are they not affected
by everything that's going on do you
think there's just more of them just
being identity based right it's like
them thinking that these are ideals of
what good democrats should be like I
think it's like Joe saying it's like
there's a correct there's a huge group
of people who just they're not anymore
yeah and that's it yeah yeah yeah
because the other side is too evil for
them to even consider this is what
Democrats do here's an example right so
here's an example in my karate club
there's a lot of like guys that are from
50 to 70 something and they're hardcore
Democrats they're not the progressives
they're not the woke Libs they're not
those guys they're old school liberals
meaning guys maybe during the time they
were union workers they were working
class guys
Democrats used to be the camp that
represented uh the teachers union the
longshoremen the police department
working class men right and then the
Republicans used to be the guys that
represented big business crony Capital
yeah right that used to be their era the
work they're still stuck in thinking
that that's still the camps and what
they represent today so as long as you
kind of like do some speaking points
where it's like okay yeah we're still
kind of left then you're still appealing
to those 60 70 year olds that will vote
with them that's completely different
from like let's say uh the aocs and the
in the in the new generation yeah who
speaks to maybe the Millennials in gen Z
do they're not corporators do they not
watch the news so like for example like
all the super left people that want to
defund the police right and then now we
have the repeat criminals that are
coming the catch and release programs do
they not tie those things together with
what they see do they still they live in
gated communities they're not seeing
that [__] but I think I think on the
news that they watch it but they don't
watch that news the dur news is saying
that's not happening well no no I think
I think if they truly believe that the
Democratic party is there to protect
minorities and the weak and the
Republican Party are racist white people
who hate minorities then you're gonna
just vote left no matter what because
you don't want white supremacy to win so
that's also a lot of people's
mentalities right is both camps use
fear-mongering on the right they go yeah
do you want these dirty ass [__]
liberal supposed to come in and teach
your kids how to [__] right like
bananas they're putting condoms on
bananas yeah sure yeah exactly yeah so
what they'll do is on both sides they'll
exaggerate true weird things that are
happening and then they'll blow it the
[__] up and scare the [__] out of their
constituents and you know what actually
to mold myself a little bit like to to
get mode a little bit I remember saying
for years that the right would use
abortion as a weapon but they would
never actually do it but then they
[__] did it with Roe v Wade so I'm
like I take it back I was wrong I was
[__] wrong they're [__]
Psychopaths with that [__] yeah I don't
know what the [__] they're doing with
that [__] that is true what you're
saying it's like I think they do see it
and they still think it's worse to
switch sides
because because now it's like yeah and I
can understand it's like well I'm a
woman and I could get pregnant and like
I maybe I don't want to keep the baby or
I have a medical issue and some people
are like you can't do [__] about it [__]
you so like maybe that's the only thing
I'm gonna vote for and it doesn't matter
if you're gonna lose your AC later like
you know I wanna I care about this issue
the right is wild about abortion dude I
think conservatives do the same thing
they see a lot of of stuff too that
maybe is objectively bad but they're
still like well I ain't gay I ain't
gonna be a Democrat you know what I mean
it's like something as dumb as that plus
I don't think you and I as the common
voter are not the people to turn the top
hide either yeah I think it's more of
like who's benefiting monetarily from
the government being the way it is and I
think that just branches down to all the
people that are lobbying and they're
like hey we need to keep things the way
they are because you're gonna make a lot
of money when you can't use ACS or gas
those anymore so we need to keep this
[__] going the way that it is and then I
think they Lobby to their communities
and they say whatever the [__] they have
to to make people mad enough to stay on
that side I dare them to in closing I
dare them to ban a season government
facilities first they won't they won't
do that yeah no ban gas stoves in uh
science centers and [__] yeah if you're
the one do it first in your own home
Gavin Newsom do you have [__] Bunsen
burners in your house my brother-in-law
runs a lab
nope no burners for you brother sorry
bud they're okay with meth labs having
the burners
I would say they're private I would say
like so so so this is this this is
actually something that's been on my
mind right which is one voter turnout
right so you would see all these things
happening you're like why isn't anyone
doing anything well okay voter turnout
we had the most that we ever did in the
in the last election which was 62 or
something so of eligible voters we had
about half of people actually voting
okay and out of those half of eligible
voters right like how many of them
actually studied and then voted yeah
right and then so like out of that like
the people that are actually making
decisions political decisions or like
voting in different peoples in office
you really got a second to make you know
to capture their decisions but most
people already made their decisions
because they're gonna vote based on what
their church is going to do based on
their community based on their culture
because there's also I always thought
about about this too is like a lot of
minorities are more conservative in
their beliefs about uh heterosexual like
you know Lifestyles or like or like
thinking that like uh they're very
Christian or they're very Muslim or
whatever so they're actually more right
in philosophy but why did they vote left
and it's because in the past the Dems
opened up the door for minorities to
actually participate in politics at a
bigger scale even though the reality is
there are people of color in the right
you know the first Asian politician that
made it big time I think he was a
senator from Hawaii he was a republican
yeah there's like a lot of different
examples of that but because there's
part because of that like oh you were
first to let us in there's Party Loyalty
this is my Legions yeah yeah so true so
even if it changed and like maybe they
don't need that anymore but I feel like
you know you do have the first Senator
the first governor all the Asian
American prominent guys in the
Democratic party they I feel like
they're just tied to that yeah
foreign